[Music]
in self appraised use I love me I love
me some me too yeah submitted by a
sponsor JK yeah any company will be down
to sponsor and promotion about this
jakey news is brought to you by playboy
people is on that bad I'll talk to you
by pedigree dog food no point of goods
like partners up with people whatever
great to we just need money I heard
they're paying three point five K for
amateur videos for what your videos no
[ __ ] yeah do my iPhone quick three point
five K today me and you guys do it
explode it many else will do it together
I'm not good together
we'll each will you have a different
angle each a mayor in New Jersey forgot
to switch accounts when praising himself
on Facebook love that multiple accounts
that he made any frames themselves this
isn't even that bad do you know Kevin
Durant
yeah it's literally top five you could
argue best player in the NBA he got
caught on his own account arguing with a
troll on Twitter he's like so he posted
something some kid crushes them yeah and
then he forgot to switch accounts and
he's like Kevin Durant's really really
good or something stupid back at this
kid from Kevin Durant so he has another
court like account to guard himself how
much like how many celebrity know they
might be lurking on a big account on
just yeah a lot of people like us to do
it like are people like that do what we
do do it but you would never think like
high level well because so I'm not think
I think you're thinking literally Kevin
Durant aspect I'm thinking his intern or
assistant is doing it I forgot to say I
think it's Kevin
I think he's Kevin because I think
self-esteem I think self-esteem of those
people at that levels messed up in mind
probably even worse but I did I didn't
think that they would have the time to
do that or the balls everyone has time
you know a lot of people are like how do
you have the time every
has our president has yeah it's my
perception of that though that's stupid
you're like oh why they even care you
haven't liked your busy ball ball
everyone has time just because you're
[ __ ] crushes and text you back
because he said so doesn't have time
doesn't mean everyone else doesn't at
all right do that hurt yeah I do with
Mike where it's like someone like Kevin
Durant who like has his own airport
entrance someone that flies in a private
jet like you're just thinking he's on
this above human level and it's crazy
that like no he's just as petty like
everybody else and his persona has like
at least you see it in the media as like
the good guy like he's nice to people
he's obviously really good you know but
he's not like the [ __ ] in the NBA
like he's the good guy names I thought I
liked her too he just clowns on herself
I thought like if I had like nine
figures in my bank account I I don't
know I don't know if these things would
bother me but I might but am I you know
who knows well you get crushed now and
you're not out there hating bad are you
I'm not so I already don't care so I
already feel like if I got nine fingers
I would care even less I agree
may I'm gonna make fake accounts I never
thought about that you can make some
fake ones for me I'll make fake ones for
you to own protect each other we don't
it would be funny sure they're for
backup yeah this guy let's all get up
guy to me once you for her bikini I wish
I knew like how many celebrity special
you have those little Heidi accounts
that they talk gun I mean why why is it
so hard to just block yeah
or ignore delete but sometimes it's fun
[ __ ] out of people yeah cuz sometimes
just like COD you're so [ __ ] stupid
yeah are you this stupid alright so the
mayor of Hoboken
that's I'm in a real place you lie New
Jersey I've heard of it yeah and I've
heard it's such a funny word no New
Jersey's I in a real place
that's our scene I was only on TV Jersey
Shore that's the only part of Jersey
that I know by the way Hell's Kitchen is
a real place and no idea you didn't
no [ __ ] clue I thought it was just in
daredevil I only found out about it
because I love mafia movies and they
always take place in New York I heard
about it in daredevil and then when I
went to New York like 2015 I like a
snapchat whatever filters and it said
Hell's Kitchen I was like holy [ __ ] why
is it called Al's kitchen no let me tell
you about Hoboken though this mayor his
name is Robbie Bala
this is the mayor of Elba and he has a
great beer no you got the job [ __ ] y'all
I don't know if he's got his beard is
sick Aziza see thank you oh I don't know
if it's his two front teeth upper teeth
or his bottom teeth he didn't say sick
alright so he looks like he posted this
on Facebook would you like to read it he
looks like you'd be a [ __ ] he would tip
of your vagina
he said spent the evening knocking on
doors at 70 Adams Street to drop off
water bottle water bottles and update
residents on current situations Wes says
water should be back on in the next two
to three hours that's his post
oh my god he's such a good person you're
talking to city people all that right
Steve did you get my ankle is this angle
better just one shake should I put my
hand higher or lower wait close the door
pretend I'm not here again Louie lucky
nothing again hey can we get a
three-legged dog next to me I would have
a feedom a treat that's the one place
everybody back to one thank you so then
a comment on this post Rafi is the best
guy in the world
thanks for the hands-on work and
unrelenting pressure you're placing on
sweats its meted and necessary he's
trying to rev himself up but he forgot
to change accounts he's give himself a
little self-love I like it so then
that's when someone's like you realize
you posted this comment yourself right I
don't think it's about what do you think
happens to these videos I got like 12
youtubes I don't hop down like
Sallah marks the best gifts y'all ever
had hit that fool on there right good
handsome funny makes so many emails oh
yeah sacrificed a winded hey
signing out of my but not anymore you
can't be signed into multiple things
like your email account but you still
got to make all of those true yeah viral
on Twitter freely you know you can ask
people on Instagram I like hey ask me
question my story don't answer it and
then somebody asked him I love your
music so much when are you going to blow
like what I love your music are you in
release Maurice I go yeah I'm working
hard but there's something like you know
if you're the owner of the account
you're the only one that can see this
part right so we know it's you asking
your own [ __ ] questions and he just
got called out for it it's one of the
most embarrassing things I've ever
received
yeah don't confuse I don't get it for
instance it's like you can see on the
question and on the bottom says answer
here or like I'll send to ask question
where it's basically something you can
only see a girl mm-hmm all right so then
what they're saying here is that it
wasn't the mayor Robbie
it was actually his brother that was
using that account it was my brother my
phone that doesn't make it better yeah
yeah yeah revenue him up yeah it's go
bad better but it still bad he
immediately took responsibility he
tweeted this out he's like I'm not Ravi
nor his staff mistakenly put up that
comment thinking that I was encouraging
Robbie people in your ward don't have
water and you're trying to score
political points pathetic next time ask
and next time ask and do your homework
what what's he who's he's insulting oh
the other person that said like oh ma I
called him on our winners twin brother
and it just looks like a rival person oh
I wasn't have to do homework because he
literally just called it out do your
homework get my algebra ready [ __ ] what
do you want him do like call his brother
me like hey was it accidentally you
those long as account or was it actually
you know Robbie like what homework is
there to do is a hobo
known for something yeah is it like the
super-rich Pardo's named Ken Hoboken
hobo cam yeah that's all for something
right is it the rich neighborhood in
Jersey a lot of celebrities living yeah
I heard of it but I just don't remember
what a famous for fraud races frog races
yeah at the bloke oh boy he's a really
magical place you guys yeah I don't know
but that just it was just so funny how
immediately the brother wanted to take
credit for it yeah you got a text from
April I need you right now bro hop on
Facebook
give me your pass yeah I get my [ __ ] all
the time
oh sorry that wasn't me who sent the
dick pic it was my friend he was messing
around oh sorry well awesome kid like
came into my facebook stream and talk
[ __ ] but you they don't realize it's
your real profile you idiot so someone
messaged him like hey you do realize
that we have your profile in your city
and where you live and your family where
he goes oh my god I'm so sorry it was my
girlfriend oh I got Cathy I got her
that's like asking for a friend
yeah oh sorry I was hacked yeah all
right it wasn't me I was holding it for
a friend huh no it's funny it's so easy
to catch who the [ __ ] is like faking a
door has a fake account or whatever
because all of them would create it like
in the same month or whatever and then
they don't have any tweets on their
thing or they don't have any you know
like there's no activity like you can
totally tell
so the real good people are the ones
that mature the count over time and it
looks like there's activity and yeah but
there's fewer that do this actually
where they create fake [ __ ] and then
it's just over time and then they use it
later to comment on other things
just like when guys want to be gassed up
a Slade so they want a lot of hot girls
on their Instagram and all that stuff
and then you click on every single one
it looks like real people but they're
not it's like it's almost like troll
farms yeah yeah one kid that I caught
scamming my friend out of the jacket his
his scam account for selling like babe
stuff was like if you've had a good
experience with me please comment below
any comments it on his personal account
saying oh I've had such a great
experience with this guy I bought it in
blah blah blah blah blah but I looked at
it it was a it was a name of the owner
of this gamma cam
so you can tell you know we're stupid
wow they're so smokers right like just a
little bit of effort but not like all
the ways at least change one letter in
the name or something I feel like when
you get caught from that [ __ ] though or
like when you get scammed it's kind of
like you deserved it cuz it's easy like
you just got a look around a little bit
it's all hard being dishonest just so
much work yeah
just build your actual account yeah
they're just so real [ __ ] yeah I just
don't have [ __ ] well you've been like
trolling and like people hatin and [ __ ]
it's like they use other people's
pictures that catfish yeah
they fake who they are and [ __ ] and it's
like why because they don't want to get
caught that's like the ultimate [ __ ]
move dude like why can't you just talk
[ __ ] as who you are on your really tell
ya on your real account like that's what
normal people should do they're even
scared of being like having [ __ ] talk
back to them online like that's the
weird [ __ ] you know like you're
refreshing until they see something I
don't want them to cuss at the real me I
want them to cuss at the picture of
Peter Pan or some [ __ ] you know that's
how much of a [ __ ] you guys are it's so
weird it's like dude I look like a
thousand miles away from you what are
you scared of that's some bad [ __ ] or
it's like sometimes when I'm at night in
someone comments like you know those
give away things like tag 3 friends tag
3 friends and I get tagging them I just
like sometimes I was fun I don't know
you don't tag me oh sorry it wasn't me
it was my it was my sister I didn't mean
see like 90% of times like oh I didn't
mean to like shut up it's not that big
of a deal just don't utter your deal
just say just apologize and move on yeah
like what the [ __ ] man I'm not gonna
punch you in the face when they see you
or instead of that instead of saying it
wasn't mean they'll be like oh my god
you actually respond I just wanted
attention alright I [ __ ] hate those
oh I'm talking [ __ ] cuz I didn't think
you would respond oh my god I just want
you to respond [ __ ] you will kill
yourself
[Music]